look at you look at you you look so  Armenian were you nervous for this you  look like Sam right here no if I was you  know I was probably nervous  but but once you get the first life it  was such a great crowd wow that's cool I  look cool yeah Chris Tucker on there too  what okay  I hit it  do you belong here too man you're here  it looks good out of control too much  that was 2017 yeah it's 2017. now if you  do late night no it wasn't it was  earlier than that  oh this is a big fat Eric  I used to call him uh that's why I used  to call him Charlie's Angels [ __ ] hair  me oh yeah  yeah dude  like Chris would just be like you know  that's funny  yeah look at that dude wow isn't it  crazy to see that [ __ ] this one I just  had a mustache I'm gonna look back on  this and be like what was I do  um cool uh yeah two guys who did it  cuter  I wish you were put in a ponytail no it  doesn't look good with me yeah  before yeah that's what I want yeah yeah  and In fairness that's what he wants